[Music]
so
i am really so thrilled
to introduce our next keynote speakers
um martin watenberg and fernando
villegas
because martin and fernanda
i believe are really two of the top
visualization researchers
in the world today i have been a
follower of their work
for over 10 years the chances are
you have seen some of their work before
in fact if you've ever like looked up
the definition of a word on google and
seen the little line chart i believe
that is
martin's most popular almost well seen
visualization
my one of my personal favorites is the
wind map really beautiful visualization
of uh of of dynamic wind currents over
the continental us if you google wind
map
fantastic fantastic visualization but
recently
fernando and martin have been working on
using visualization
to display really complex ideas and
unpack
many of the tools of modern machine
learning and artificial intelligence
so please join me in welcoming fernando
and martin
thank you thank you thank you
so yeah thank you so much
want to talk a little bit about what
we're doing now because it uh
combines both visualization which has
been our bread and butter for a while
uh with ai we uh our co-leads uh
with jeff holbrook of a group at google
called pair
stands for people plus ai research and
before saying
anything more about it i want to quickly
put up
pictures of the people in the team
because i want to emphasize
that everything we're talking about
today this was all very much a team
effort and and these people
deserve credit uh
the the sort of mission of pair is to
uh make machine learning and artificial
intelligence productive enjoyable and
fair
uh and we do that in various ways and
one of which i'm happy to say actually
we release a fair number of open source
tools
which we will we'll talk about today uh
we also
create educational materials academic
publications
uh and do a lot of public work as well
now
you might ask why are we talking about
human ai
interaction at this conference and
there's sort of a snarky
answer you could give which is it some
might say ai is just
fancy statistics then maybe there's some
truth to that
but there is kind of a more serious
answer
which is that you as people who analyze
data you have a lot of power and you
know that
but you might have even more power than
you realize
that as ai becomes more and more
pervasive
it's turning out that data analysis is
very much the key
to getting ai right
so to start with we're going to start at
the beginning we have a few projects
we'd like to share with you
and one of them is about just
visualizing training data
i'm sure you all know this that
a big part of what goes into these
massive machine learning systems
is the data and you need to be super
careful and mindful about the data
and yet when we talk with engineers
software engineers
about some of the problems that come up
in these systems
their first instinct tends to be to
debug their program
and so our favorite motto is debug your
data first
not your program and this is something
of a learning curve
and i think you all are way ahead of the
engineers
but one of the realities is that we need
tools
for dealing with the huge amounts of
data that
these people are using um and so we're
still working on that
one example of a tool we created which
is a visualization for
for just training data um i'm going to
demo that with one of the
hello world data sets of machine
learning
which is called c510 and all it is it's
a bunch of
images square little images um
of 10 different classes of things
each image has just one main object or
entity inside of it and the entire data
set has been
human labeled in these 10 different
classes
so you have deer you have car you have
automobile and so forth and so
and and another thing that's important
about this data set
is that because it is one of the hello
world data sets
of machine learning it is used
everywhere it is used as a benchmark
it's been used by thousands of people
all over the world
and it's used in publications as well
so how do i get maybe that x
let's see
let's get to the demo okay cool
so this is our little visualization and
uh it's called facets and all i'm doing
here is visualizing
uh the images i have just by the
different classes so
as far as data visualization goes it's
extremely straightforward
right i can zoom in i can
look at images very closely if i want
see how pixelated they are
and so forth nothing super special you
can see
the labels of the classes and you can
also see that if i accidentally click
on any one of the images it brings up a
little card at the very top there
with the metadata about about each one
of these images
okay so on so far nothing special
but even this is hard for
regular engineers using machine learning
systems to
to get to see they don't usually get to
see their training data
and the reason why i'm sure you all
realize
why you want to do something like this
is because it could be that half of your
data set
is just empty it's just blank images or
even
worse than that it could be that just
one of your classes is blank
and nothing else and so you want to be
able to just very quickly
play with your data and look at it once
we have this we can play little games
right so
i can look at the same visualization but
i can now
distribute it by hue and i can see that
there are different bulges in
in different classes so i can see that
airplane at the very top and ship
towards the bottom are the
classes with the most uh blue
images right that kind of makes sense
i'm taking images i'm taking photos
against the sky or against the water
and then all of my animal classes
kind of in the middle bird cat deer
they tend to hang out more on the earthy
tones
okay so far so good now i can do other
things i can say
now show me a confusion matrix and all
it is a confusion matrix is
basically me trying to understand how in
sync
humans and my machine learning system
really are so everything on the column
there
are the labels that have been manually
given to these images by humans
and everything at the top are the labels
that my system is giving
as it tries to classify these images so
the good news for me
is that that diagonal is by far the most
populated set of
of uh cells i have there because that's
where humans and machine
agree so that's great um but then
other things i can do with this i can
say okay so now let's
filter out all the correct guesses i'm
gonna filter out that diagonal
and then immediately i have all the
mistakes that my system is making
and i can see an interesting pattern
here
i can see that my most populated
cell or couple of cells over here
and over here is the intersection
between
cats and dogs my system is kind of
confused between cats and dogs right
so it could be that at this point i go
back and give my system
more examples of cats and dogs so we can
retrain and hopefully get better at
these classes
this could be one of one of the things i
do all right another thing i can do with
this visualization
is look at the soft max label so towards
the
end of my network i want to understand
not only
how these images are being classified by
my system
but i also want to understand how sure
my system is how certain my sister
system is of
any of those classifications it it makes
so the way to read this is
the more an image is to the right the
more
certain my system is that that is indeed
a dog
or a cat or an airplane and everything
the more to the right
the more correct it is
uh on the contrary the more to the left
you have
these over here the more certain my
system is that that is not a cat
or not an airplane and those are
incorrect classifications so one of the
things i might want to do
here is i might want to go we
we became interested we're like oh wow
but check it out
cats is still very populated here
there's a bunch of cats my system is
very very sure
are not cats so we zoomed in
and started looking like wow what do
these cats look like that my system just
very certain aren't cats right
and again think back that this is
a benchmark data set used
by lots of people all over the world
we started looking at this and we're
like
there is totally a thing there that's
not a cat
can you can anyone spot it's towards
it's on the second row to the bottom
over here my system is very sure that's
a frog
and so am i
and yet it has been labeled by humans
as a cat okay so
what is our little tale telling us here
the same tale as usual you have to go
back to your data and look at it and
there are going to be mistakes
and if you can't look at it in an easy
way
you're going to continue to see these
mistakes over
and over again so
this was a tool that we started using
internally
and then decided this is actually a
simple straightforward tool that's
actually super
useful um and we decided to to open
source so facets
is is a is a open source tool available
for anyone
um and yes i know that you can do this
in r and i'm sure that
a lot of you are doing it already right
slice and dicing
simple simple stuff but there's a lot of
people
who don't use r2 and so having something
on the web
is is also useful
all right the next thing we want to talk
about is this notion that
as soon as you start feeding these
massive data sets
to these machine learning systems you
are going to be talking
about bias and skews in your data set
and as soon as you start deploying these
systems
in the world you are going to be faced
with
fairness questions um and so
one of the things and these are very
complicated these are very complex
issues right
it's not like you have a technical
solution for these things
um but there is also a technical piece
to trying to solve some of these things
so
martin and i were interested in whether
we could use
very simple data visualization to start
illustrating
some of the trade-offs that you have to
make when you start thinking about
fairness and machine learning and so
we're going to play
as i introduce this visualization it's
very simple we're going to play a little
game here
which is we're going to imagine that we
are a bank
and we're deciding who we're going to
give loans to
and who we're going to not give loans to
so
each one of these dots is a person who
comes to our bank
asking for a loan okay they have a
credit score all of these things are
imaginary my credit score goes from zero
to a hundred
and their location is is
um reflects their credit score
okay each one of the
light uh colored dots would defeat
would default on our on our loan
any all of the dark colored dots would
pay us back
so in other words we want to give loans
to the dark colored dots
and we do not want to give loans to the
light color dots
okay many people come to our our bank
we set a threshold below that threshold
we don't give loans
above that threshold we give loans so
far so good
except that in reality
life is not that simple right so no
matter where
i put my threshold chances are i'm going
to be denying loans to people who would
pay me back
and i would be giving loans to people
who default
okay and so this is still
a simplification of the real world but
it's a distribution that starts to
look a little bit more realistic and you
can see that no matter where you put
your threshold you're going to make
incorrect guesses right okay
then the next question becomes
well you may have different populations
of users coming of
of people coming to your bank and asking
for loans
and you may know that these
distributions are different
for these different people and so how
are you going to be fair
in deciding now that you have a blue
population and an orange population with
different distributions how are you
going to decide
how to be fair um and
there are many different ways you can do
this so let me
just show you the little demo slash
visualization
we created this accompanies by the way
a paper on machine learning fairness
so basically we just created this
little simulation here which is kind of
what you had been seeing before
and it's interactive and i can play with
it and you can see what happens
underneath
as i'm changing the threshold here at
the top
at the bottom you can see the percentage
of
incorrect and correct guesses i make
okay you can also see things at the
bottom here
these pie chart things they stand for
the positive rate of
loans i give so in other words of all
the people who come to my bank
what is the percentage of people i give
loans to
and then there's another pie chart that
says sorry
the positive rate is on the right
true positive rate is on the left true
positive rate means
of all the people who come to my bank
and would pay me back what is the
percentage of people i give
loans to so i can play with this stuff i
can play with them independently
and the other thing i want to make sure
because i'm a bank
is i want to make a profit at the end of
the day
so how do i do these things and still
how can i be fair
so we put some presets here at the on
the left
one is if you if you don't want to be
fair at all click on maximum profit
there it is
that's what your threshold should be
given the distributions okay
if you do want to be fair all right
maybe what you want to do
is you want to be group unaware so i
clicked on group unaware and you can
see that what this means is i have the
same thresholds for both populations
right so i don't care if you're blue i
don't care if you're orange
you're gonna be treated the same because
that's the most fair thing to that's the
the fair thing to do
okay that could be
except that when we start looking at the
positive
rates here i can see that
of all the people who pay me back the
blue people i give rate i give loans to
81
of them versus only 60
of the orange people okay
is that fair well maybe the next thing
you could try is
something called demographic parity and
demographic parity
optimizes for the same positive rate
so of all the blue and all the orange
people who come
to my uh to my bank i try to give the
same percentage
of uh of loans again what this means is
my thresholds are different
quite different for these different
groups
is that fair maybe maybe not the last
thing here i have is equal opportunity
which
optimizes for a true positive rate so
anyway
long story short there are many
different
ways to think about being fair
and how do you translate those values
into math
for deciding in a scenario like this
the point of doing this was that martin
and i were interested
if with a very simple abstract scenario
like this
with a simple visualization that people
could just play with
if they could start to develop a certain
intuition
for the trade-offs that happen when
you're actually trying to decide
this on a system and it was interesting
to see
that this simple visualization went kind
of viral
on the web and we started seeing people
have these really interesting
discussions of
oh wow i always thought that you know
demographic parity was the way to go but
now i see that
whatever equal opportunity is maybe a
more
interesting way to think about fear and
just to be clear
there are many many more metrics of
fairness
that have come up since then also in the
literature
right and i think that's not gonna
that's not going to stop um another part
of the conversation that we saw online
that is i think very important is people
realizing
oh and you can't have all of these at
once
there is no perfect solution right it's
always a trade-off and you're going to
have to choose
and so we started getting emails and so
for instance one of the emails we got
was from a criminal justice department
in the u.s saying we saw
this visualization do you think we could
uh
create something like this for our own
uh department so that we start to
understand what the trade-offs are that
we're making
with the systems we're using obviously
we're not a bank
but would is this this would be a
very powerful way to have people in the
department
engage with these questions right and so
based on this and on the reaction we got
let me go back
we decided to go from that toy
simulation to
actually trying to put together an
actual tool that allowed you
to do some of this playing around with
your
with your model and with with testing
your model for different scenarios
and so this is a tool we created called
the what if tool
and this is a code-free probing tool for
machine learning systems
that allows you to test for some of
these scenarios
to say things like oh what if i want
demographic parity
in the different slices of my data what
thresholds should i use
in my model it allows you to do things
like
click on a data point and say
for instance let's go back to the loan
scenario
and say oh this person did not get a
loan
okay let me go back to the next slide
here this person did not get a loan who
is the nearest person
to that one that did get alone and what
is the delta there
so a little notion of counter factual if
you will
without the causality that's a separate
conversation
but just this notion of starting to try
to understand
what's happening with these systems how
they are behaving
asking a bunch of alternative scenarios
trying a bunch of edge cases and also
playing with notions of fairness uh of
how different slices
of your data set are doing uh vis-a-vis
one another
this too is open source so it is
available
for anyone it is also been integrated
into google's
cloud ai so that anyone using that
platform
can now play with these alternative
scenarios and test things for themselves
before they decide to launch something
or to try to debug situations
and i think one of the really important
things here too is the fact that we're
not expecting that you need to be
a phd in machine learning to to ask
these probing questions uh many more
people should be um engaging
and experimenting with uh the way these
systems behave
so i think the story so far is if you're
seeing how
important data analysis is in all of
this um and then i think also
when you look at machine learning
fairness there's this issue number one
that trying to make the world better to
try to do the right thing involves
statistics
however also if you are deploying models
this is something you now have to think
about or you should have been thinking
about all along indeed
uh and i think that's an important
change of mindset
for many people that we've seen and
again statistics is a key part of this
there's something else going on though
which is that using data analysis
you can actually end up finding new ways
to control
ai systems and to explain that we're
going to take a journey
through high dimensional space to
understand the superpower
okay so let's talk about data in high
dimensions and we're going to introduce
a couple of uh things in a row here
let's start with a warm-up and for our
warm-up
we're going to visualize another famous
hello world data set from machine
learning
a data set of little 28 by 28 icons that
represent
handwritten digits that is often used to
test very simple
machine learning models and what we're
going to talk about
is how you can think about each of these
images as a vector in high dimensional
space
and the trick which is familiar i'm sure
to to
some if not many of you is that we look
at the pixels
and we give them all values in this case
we'll say black is zero
white is one and intermediate values get
some floating point number
and then we just list the values of all
the pixels in a row
and that gives us a vector so for
example this vector would turn into
something that looks like that
uh other other images would look
turn into other vectors okay
so why have we done this well this is
going to be sort of our our example data
set
as we look at a visualization that we
call the embedding projector
so let's take a look
all right yes so now you see rotating
you are looking at 784 dimensional space
here
um what you are actually seeing of
course
is a two-dimensional projection of a
three-dimensional
view of this high-dimensional space that
is using principal component analysis to
project these linearly
um and that's definitely an interesting
thing but
it also is kind of a big blob you know
as much as it's
one can ooh and ah over this it's a
little bit hard to make sense of
so let's take another view
let's look at a different way of looking
at this
okay now we're using a method called
umap that is designed
to take high-dimensional space
and instead of using a linear projection
it's using a non-linear projection
that has many complicated properties
which we'll talk about in a moment but
the basic idea
is that it one thing it does tend to
preserve is clustering
and so one thing that i can do um is
since this is our data set and we have
labels
i can label i can color
these digits by their label and that
lets us easily see for example
that in general you know all the ones
are at a certain area
all the fours are another area and so
forth but we can also see it doesn't
completely get it right
like it thinks this three it clearly
thinks belongs with the twos this eight
looks like a two and so forth already
i think this view can tell you a bunch
of interesting things
um one thing is just that
apparently these digits are actually
pretty well separated like you can see
why this is not the hardest
machine learning task in the world that
there is just some natural clustering
structure that is
you know even a visualization method
brings it out
pretty well one other thing that's kind
of nice though
is that if you look even within these
clusters you can start to see some
interesting structure for example in
these ones
you'll notice that they're kind of
tilted to the left on this side
they're tilted to the right on this side
and you really can
start to get a sense of what the
geometry looks like
in this high dimensional space
okay so let's see i'll go
back there
what else can we do with high
dimensional space
uh well let's see um i think
if there's time at the end we might talk
a little bit about
what these mean but i think i might skip
this i do i will say that among the
educational materials that we've been
putting out
are are sort of step-by-step interactive
essays
about how to interpret these complicated
nonlinear projections because they're
amazing
but weird and the weirdness can be your
friend but you have
and sometimes problematic so you want to
be aware of that
yeah um okay
so another kind of word high dimensional
object which
turns out to be very very useful is
something called a word embedding
so word embedding it's it's sort of a
weird terminology but what it just means
is you're mapping words into
points in high dimensional space much
the way we mapped those
images however with images there was a
pretty straightforward way of doing it
by using pixels with words it's actually
sort of complicated and i won't get into
exactly how that is done there are
actually a couple of ways and the
interesting thing is they often produce
similar results
if you do it well the idea is usually to
make sure that related words
end up near each other and in fact it
turns out you can do this
however when people figured out ways to
make that happen
they discovered a really interesting and
surprising fact
which is not only can you get a
situation where similar words are near
each other
but almost as a byproduct like seemingly
as an accident
you get meaningful directions in space
and so the image that you're seeing here
is
is a figure from one very famous early
paper in which
they showed that there's like a
direction in space that corresponds to
the relationship
of a capital to the country it is a
capital of
which is really amazing okay
so let's take a look just because we
have our visualization up
of what those word embeddings look like
and i'm going to show this in a couple
of ways so
this is just a raw pca view
this is a umap view and let's actually
play with us a little bit
um let us explore this because i think
it really gives a sense
of you're you're seeing the english
language here this is the geometry of
english
and what can we say about it well look
there's obviously clumps
let's go spelunking a little bit what is
this clump here oh look
a bunch of names it seems like you know
largely maybe boys names here
and then uh let's see if we get some
other names for people yeah i'll read
them lloyd alex
matt joel what about
this cluster here horns percussion
guitar quartet face we found the music
cluster over there
what about these oh look we have some
numbers um and oops let's see if we can
zoom in on them
uh zero one two three
we can actually see and in fact if we
zoomed in more we could almost see
a little bit of a linear structure
representing those
we have some other uh things here let's
see infinity angle
math bf look we found the tech world
here
so there really is everything and this
gives you a sense of
just how much information this is
encoded here
but now i want to show one more thing
and that is um
let's do something a tricky let's go
back to
let's do a custom embedding and the way
this works is we actually can
define an access in terms of one word to
another word
right now it's just a 2d projection it's
linear and both axes are random
but let's let's actually search for a
word and look at some neighbors
let's see what's a good one how about uh
science
i'll click on this we'll isolate those
100 points
and now we can sort of see the neighbors
of the word science in pca
but now let's actually do a custom thing
and we can play this little game
where say we look at uh let's look at
man on the left and woman on the right
and suddenly we see something really
interesting
that um now the left right at the x-axis
left to right
has things that it's thinking are closer
to the word man
um versus woman and this is actually a
little bit sad that you can sort of see
like technical is its most male word
here in this neighborhood
um and meanwhile on the
female side although we do a scientist
we see religion
author stories psychology and this is
actually a sobering moment when people
started to realize this about these
embeddings
i think they just realized how serious
things had become that you know
these things had been trained on huge
corpora of existing words
of language and those had contained
a bunch of biases and this
new word embedding was very efficiently
encoding some of those
so in fact we can show a couple of other
examples this is you know the
neighborhood of engineer shows
many of the similar things uh if you do
a neighborhood of math
i want to read it yeah you can see you
know geometry computational on the man
side again
psychology art library
on the women's side and it's not even
just
uh you know sort of the big famous
biases um
like gender or something but you know
you can like even something like old and
new
and not with people you can sort of see
interesting things that are meaningful
like with if i put in book
and look at its neighbors i see for old
i see things like
poem and manuscript on the new side i
see like
company for instance magic and
you know you can start to see it's it's
picking up on important associations but
in a way that is potentially problematic
uh okay so we have this thing that's
powerful
it requires a lot of analysis but let's
think about how we could use this idea
of meaningful directions in
other ways now that we have it so one
way
it turns out is to interpret what's
going on inside of neural networks so
that they're not in fact black boxes
and i'd like to very quickly fly through
a method called
tcav um published in uh
icml 2018 and the idea behind this
method is to take this insight that okay
if things like word embeddings have
directions that sort of correspond to
you know things that are meaningful to
humans like capital cities
uh to capitals maybe there are other
types of embeddings that have that same
property and we've used that to our
advantage
so i'll illustrate this by
imagining a question you might ask of an
image classifier
let's say it looks at a picture of a
zebra and
you wonder why did it think that thing
was a zebra um
so there's sort of a bad answer to this
question and a good answer
the bad answer is if it told you
something like oh it was this particular
pixel
um or these sets of pixels because
that's not those are not terms that a
human can understand
a much better answer would be if it
could say something like oh it was
striped
and that helped of course it's very hard
to kind of figure out how to extract
that answer
however there is a way to do it so let's
follow what happens
if you have a neural network that is
recognizing an image like zebra
so you put in an image let's say it's an
image of a zebra
and then it will you put it into your
neural network and what is shown here is
a little cartoon of one famous network
called inception and the idea is that
in this kind of network you have the
image gets sort of transformed
layer by layer and you can think of each
layer as performing a transformation
of euclidean space um
and so for if you put something like
zebra throat show it in image
in each of these layers you can think of
the state of the layers as a set of
activations
of the neurons and those activations
form a vector in high dimensional space
so you can see how this starts to relate
to what we were just looking at
and then what's interesting is if you
put a whole bunch of images through
you get a bunch of points in this high
dimensional space
and you can start playing this game with
meaningful directions
um so let's show how this works so the
idea is that
let's say there's a concept you're
interested in for example stripes or the
presence of stripes
you don't even have to try to define the
computer
in language what stripes is you could
just show it a bunch of examples
of striped images and then you put those
striped images
through your neural network and then as
you said one
important thing this these are not
images of zebras this is just
any stripes anywhere we've done this
literally with like striped ties
and striped shirts and abstract stripes
that's a good point
and then what you'll get is a kind of
cluster of images in this space of
activations
in an intermediate layer that represents
stripes
and then you can also put a bunch of
random other images through and train a
classifier
to distinguish between the stripes and
the non-stripes and that gives you
what's called a concept
activation vector a direction in space
that represents a concept
and then this is what's cool is that you
can start calculating with that that's
something that vector is something you
can
for example take directional derivatives
to understand the sensitivity to this
concept
so computers like it but humans like it
too
because it's a human-friendly concept of
stripes that they're getting an answer
in terms of
so this turns out to actually be a very
useful technique in general there's a
lot
more we can say but what's really
interesting is that you can go
from just interpreting or understanding
directly to control
yeah so imagine that you start with this
super high dimensional space and you
find
meaning in the in that space meaning
that is also meaningful to humans
right so what i want to show you next is
an example of a project
where we used that for health care
so here's the scenario we were working
with pathologists
trying to diagnose cancer and the way
they work
is they will look at a slide of a
patient
very much like the large image you see
here
and then they will try they will very
very closely analyze this image and try
to understand
one do i believe there is their cancer
here and if so what
grade of cancer this is what's called
gleason 1
gleason 2 gleason 4. okay
and so even though there has there is an
extensive
set of work that has been done with
optimizing algorithmic trans uh
performance
to try to look at an image like this and
and say
yes there is cancer no there is no
cancer much less attention had been paid
to
actually what what kind of information
and what kind of interactions would
doctors like
to get out from a dialogue with these
systems
instead of just being given a number and
a probability
do they actually want to interact and
and direct
these systems it turns out that yes they
would like to do this
and part of the reason why they want to
do stuff like this
is because um many times
for things like sometimes there are
artifacts in these images and they want
to say
dismiss that i don't want you to pay
attention to that thing that's not
important
or there are anatomical features
that they care deeply about things like
the density of glands or whatever other
concept
and think about it those are high-level
concepts right how do you tell the
machine what i really care about are
how dense the glands are here so you can
you can do things that have been done
we're going to talk about this
but basically what we did is we created
a
set of tools that allowed pathologists
to very quickly navigate these highly
massive data sets
because again what they're trying to do
they're looking at that slide and
they're trying
to get the system to bring to them
the nearest neighbors right what is the
patient i've seen before
that has been diagnosed what is the
the closest case to this case i'm seeing
now
but that's not a one shot thing that is
the thing that's interesting it's not
just like automate that
so one of the things is just allowing
people to cut little
to say focus here that's what i want to
do
things like these have been done before
right or
once you bring me a bunch of cases that
are like the case i just highlighted for
you
now let me go deeper into one of those
cases and bring me
more closest neighbors to those place to
those cases so
in other words let me navigate by
example
i want you to pay attention to this now
now let me go back i want you to pay
attention to oh this is interesting
let's go that way
okay all of that kind of had been done
before
the thing that's new that we can do
is now with things like calves that you
just heard about
we can actually create much more
sophisticated
ways of navigating these systems in
medical concepts
so working with the pathologists they
told us
that a medical concept they deeply care
about
is something called stroma i'm not a
doctor i had no idea what this was
but for them it was super interesting so
we created a slider
where they could say show me cases like
this but with more stroma
or with less trauma or fused glands
that's another medical concept they care
deeply about
and so because again
these ml systems inside these
highly massive spaces there are
meaningful directions
we were able to map these medical
concepts to
these meaningful directions
in the system and that gave doctors a
much more powerful way
of interacting with the systems and the
one of the really important things here
is to actually for the doctor to
calibrate their trust
should i trust this should i not trust
this or even to learn
how the system works how does it behave
how does it think about edge cases
and so we actually had a user study in
this case was with
12 pathologists looking both
at a traditional machine learning system
that just gives you a prediction
with a confidence level or this system
called smiley
where you have all these different tools
that you that you can interact with
and the results were very positive
basically
um they all 12 pathologists
preferred smiley the
the level of trust was
significantly higher
and even though you would think right ah
if you could only
automate my my work for me i'd be done
they actually found a lot of uh use
uh in going back and forth but not only
that
steering the system in ways that they
cared about
okay so um yeah i think
what what you see from this is sort of
the ability of
statistical analysis to actually help
steer these systems and
i want to talk about another aspect of
this and
so here i'm going to ask you to actually
do some imagining here
and even answer some questions in your
head so situation is imagine you're
a company or non-profit whatever
you're designing a system to recommend
books to library patrons
okay and you let's imagine you have a
team of people doing this
and you have engineers uh maybe you have
someone who is
responsible for the design and i mean
that broadly in terms of user experience
or
ux as people say and you're going over a
bunch of the big decisions and small
decisions that you'll have to make
and which ones do you need to consult
that user experience designer on
and so let's just go through some
questions and
i will you can think about this um you
know does the system show one
recommendation or many
what hardware does it run on just answer
these in your head
do users see an explanation for
recommendations
which database to store your metadata in
again
when should you bother that designer
what typeface do we use for
recommendations
do we use this particular loss function
which i will not read out loud
it's tech do we allow users to
like a recommendation and should our l2
regularization constant be 9.83
okay so you might have some answers in
mind
some i think are actually kind of
obvious you know clearly you should talk
to your designer about whether you show
one recommendation or many they should
be involved in that
um i think some are not really design
issues like you know what database used
to store metadata let's see
their time is precious they don't need
to weigh in on that
however there is one weird question here
which is the loss function and we would
argue that in many cases
this may be the most important ux
decision
of all okay and which seems very
counter-intuitive you know why would a
chunk of math be a user experience issue
and the answer is that essentially in a
machine learning system your loss
function
expresses the goal of what your your
system is doing
um and that goal ultimately exactly
what happens in practice that tells you
whether people are more likely
to see bad recommendations or good ones
are they going to see similar ones or
diverse and more diverse ones and many
many other aspects
we see this anywhere recommendation
systems are used
and you know that's again kind of a
sobering thought because like
how do you understand this thing like
can a mathematician just stare at it and
figure out the effects
no but a statistician
you've got a good chance if you look at
you know
pilot tests use in practice run
simulations you've got a whole bunch of
tools to look at
and so what this says i think in the new
world that we find ourselves in with ai
is that statisticians have anyone who
works with data
has an incredibly important role to play
uh you know
the models that you create are having
broad effects
on all sorts of people as you think
about what stakeholders you want to who
you want to take care of
think about also who you want to talk to
like you know as you're writing a
formula for your loss function
maybe you should talk to a ux designer
as you do that get their opinion
uh that could be as good a moment for a
user test or
ethnography as any other moment in the
design of the system
you have a lot of power
and so even though traditionally design
may have looked like this right with the
colors
and the the values
we believe that in the current era
of machine learning design is both of
these things
it needs to be we need to start thinking
that way we believe
and so basically our thought
to leave you with today is that if you
work in
r or with data or with ml code
you are part of the user experience team
whether or not you know it
and you have a lot of power as martin
was saying
so think about that think about how
you're going to
bridge between the world of data
and what you see in the models in in
uh the data logs you see in the data
analysis you make
and what that end the end user
experience is going to be because it's
going to depend
more and more on on this bridge
and so just to leave with one resource
hopefully that could be helpful
this is this guidebook is something uh
pair launched last may
and it's it's a set of guidelines
that tries to be very concrete
about what does it mean to build and
ship
ai enabled products this is something
that took
over 150 googlers from all over the
company
come together we also had academics that
we consulted with
this was very much this came from a lot
of our internal
experience shipping ai enabled products
but this is this is something that that
needs to go
needs to be much much bigger than google
this
this is just the beginning of trying to
go from those
very lofty goals like we need to make
machine learning fair
we need to make machine learning
explainable
to the okay how do we get there
how do we do this when when i have to
ship a product in
in the next three weeks so this is
a quick view of the different chapters
that the guidebook has it's full of
samples you know do's and don'ts
on the user experience side step-by-step
guidelines
and also interactive workshop sheets and
and the whole point
is that this is going to take an entire
team
to figure out this is not just the uxers
or the engineers
or the data scientists we're going to
have to be talking
all of us together and you all hold
a lot of power in that conversation
so that's it thank you so much
[Applause]
so i'm going to add a little uh
editorial voice to you
anonymous asks why are you as
visualization experts
using pie charts
don't get me started on pie
i think they are so underrated um
i actually think there are many many
good aspects to pie charts um
they in cases where you have only a
few items like three or four and where
you're interested
in the sizes of sums of wedges that are
next to each other i actually think they
have many advantages
over bar charts there are certain
queries you can make like
is there anything that has a majority or
are there two that have
slices that have a majority compared to
a third uh
or two others that are much easier if
you look at the history of research into
pie charts
people have been trying literally since
the 1920s
to prove that they're bad and they never
really have
so don't get me started
[Applause]
so we have quite a few questions just
about like what what tools did you use
to make these visualizations
oh so um most of the things you saw
today
are uh javascript tools uh and
and we tend to code things from scratch
uh
um it's
uh i mean d3 is very helpful i also
think that um
webgl has been sort of amazing that's
been a huge
technical advance um like that when i
think about what has changed
um since when i first started doing
visualization there are
things you can do just the number of
images you can animate
at one time smoothly that's that's been
a big deal
one thing that i think we forgot to say
the embedding projector
that you saw martin demo today that's
also open source that's also available
and anyone can yeah play with it so i
had a personal question which is it
looked like one of those parts is a
ggplot2
plot correct it probably is
actually yes this is
uh taylor asks facets is a beautiful
tool for exploring image data
what what strategies do you use when
you've got non-image data like 400
variables trying to predict a class
so it depends on the type of variable so
we certainly
um do a bunch of things and the idea of
like slicing and dicing you usually have
to pick a couple of variables to focus
on
um there are a couple of things so one
is
in many cases you can actually use the
something like the embedding projector
depending on the type of variables to
do clustering um in other cases
i don't know that we have a really good
solution to offer like
and again this is exactly why i think
you the audience have power is that
there's there's a wide opening for you
to actually make a big difference in
this field by providing good tools
so um register asks literatures is
awesome for
developers but are you also thinking
about pathways for people affected
by these models so they can
self-advocate for models about models
that exclude them
yeah so one of the things that we're
working on that's a very good question i
think it's a very hard one
one of the things we're working on is
um just ai literacy
in general so we are developing a number
of educational materials
the the visualization you saw with
fairness was
one of these moments when we realized oh
these simple visualizations actually
have a lot of power
just to exactly that start to educate
people
we want way more a much broader set of
folks to be critical and to be engaged
at a certain level with with this at a
level where they feel
they they know what questions to ask of
the technology
and so all of the stuff that we work on
we
we try to make it open source make it
available publicly
but i also think that creating tools
that are code free is extremely
important
uh exactly to lower the barrier um and
to start to bridge the communities
awesome we also had kind of a few
questions like you know you are embedded
inside google which clearly like
uses a bunch of algorithms and sometimes
those algorithms are good and sometimes
they're bad
like how do you see your role in kind of
shifting how google
uses algorithms for good we like good
algorithms
and i think more importantly i think in
general
people want to do the right thing and i
think
one of the things that's important is to
give people tools to make it
sort of understandable what to do i i
one of the things that is important like
it is it's
it can be very hard to know like you
know these things are very complicated
systems
and uh the more tools that we have to
help us figure out
you know okay let's do this rather than
do that how do we make decisions around
them the better
so we definitely view ourselves as
making tools both for google and as
we open source than we want i think it's
for the whole world as well
thank you i had another personal
question which is
uh how long do you spend coming up with
like humorous and good acronyms
for your kids
no i didn't know yeah
let's see
what else do we have uh have you created
any examples to illustrate the intuition
behind adversarial
images oh yeah so we
between adversarial images uh oh okay so
no um for a moment i thought you were a
generative adversarial network so we do
have one of those something called
ganlab
but adversarial images are super
interesting and weird
um for just for those who may not have
heard of them there it's this phenomenon
that you can take an image that a
computer is correctly certain about like
it's a picture of a cat it's not a frog
or something
it for sure sees it as a cat you change
the pixels in a
tiny amount so that it's imperceptible
to a human
and all of a sudden the computer is
certain it's like a bathtub or something
and it at first it was seen as like some
sort of
weird one-off bug but what's been clear
is that it's like a pervasive thing that
happens across lots of classifiers
um i think one of the reasons i don't
think we've
created something that sort of helps
people understand it is that the
research community itself
i don't think there's a crisp
explanation it's one of the genuine
mysteries you know
there's some interesting ideas about
maybe this has to do with the high
dimensional nature of the data
and any imperfect classifier might have
these or
that in fact there are important things
that a computer picks up on in terms of
texture that the human eye is just bad
at
but i don't know that there's a final
answer to that it's therefore it's very
hard to make an easy
crisp visualization of it but it's a
great question actually it's something
probably we should try
thanks i think we'll do one last
question uh so you've showed a bunch of
tools today that uh
you can use in your browser does the
data ever go to google's server or can
you use it with like confidential data
like hyper-protected data
so anything that's available on the
cloud on google cloud you should be able
to use with your own data
and confidentiality for sure um
i mean there's a question about device
on device versus off device
and what i would say is rather than
giving a crisp answer to that up here i
would
read carefully the fine print of
whichever tool but many of these
things do in fact keep the data on
device
there is a whole other project we didn't
get to talk about today here but if you
are
interested tensorflow.js
is it brings machine learning to your
browser
and one of the perks of that
there's no install there's no download
but one of the biggest perks is
privacy because it runs all locally
nothing gets sent to any server um
and so this is we didn't have time to
talk about it today but
it's definitely worth checking out
awesome thank you so plea please join me
in thanking martin
you